Oh
welcome back for the next talk we have
Thomas Vicki talking about algorithm
trading
line thank you
so I just a quick few words about me I'm
connecting currently finishing up my PhD
at Brown where I study eight the brain
with various Bayesian methods and um at
Europe Python a couple days ago I gave a
talk on probabilistic programming so if
you're interested in that aspect of me
check it out and for a couple of years
I've been working as a quantitative
researcher at quanto peein and we're a
Boston based startup and our mission is
to build the world's first browser-based
AI with make trading platform and the
idea is algorithmic trading certainly
has been around for a while but mostly
all that is bottled up in huge hedge
funds they're very secretive and it's
not really accessible for the average
user right like how would you even get
going and many of the tools which is the
nature of the secretive business are not
open source so we're trying to to change
that and that's part of the reason why
we open-source zipline and also just up
front
quanto qian the the web platform is free
and everyone can use it so we're really
trying to give as many people access to
these tools as possible just for
motivation 84% of all stock trades are
done by computers which i think is
striking so some of those are really
just I would make strategies some of
those are just like executing orders in
a certain way but certainly there's lots
of demand for that and 84% probably your
average trader that hoots full-time job
is not to trade is not using actually
trading algorithms right to motivate
that further
I just wanted to compare the humans to
the machines here obviously a big
benefit of having algorithms is that
they are completely unemotional I
recently read a cool paper that combines
my
cognitive research with the quantitative
finance that showed that traders who are
happy actually have worst performance in
picking stocks than traders who are
depressed which is pretty interesting so
certainly the algorithm will will be
more analytical in that way it's much
faster here when I add that at canto
peen were not about high-frequency
trading or anything like that the month
the shortest resolution data that we
provide is one minute so that's a long
way from being high-frequency can
process much more data and just to keep
it a little bit more even forewarn
certainly there is no intuition of the
market or anything like that in the case
of Warren Buffett is probably mostly is
access to information that he has and
also is knowledge of the market and the
algorithms obviously that is what has to
be programmed into them the patterns and
the market dynamics so to give you a
broad overview of how are with me
trading in Python can be done in the
various steps of that process I just
want to go through the pipeline where
the first step often is just data
analysis and for that I think Python is
the perfect tool for the job many tools
that we love like panas matplotlib and
ipython as i want to highlight
Seabourn which is a library on top of my
plot clip and generates really pretty
graphs statistical graphs right out of
the box so I encourage everyone to check
it out I almost use it exclusively now
so then you come up with your idea and
you want to test it right you want to
know well does that have Lex so you
implement a trading strategy around that
and test whether that idea can be
exploited and for that Python did not
use to have anything really and zip line
is one of the two tools now the other
ones pilot or trader and then again
quanto peon which we use for which we
use sublime
so zipline is actually the backtest
underlying everything we do on canto
pian for the back testing so once you're
back to us with your data you want to
forward test it or paper trade in live
market data and that's currently not
really possible with open source on
quanto pian we just started doing that
so there you can deploy your algorithm
and see how it would do with real market
data coming in and then as last step if
you're convinced then you want to put
real money behind that I with them and
life traded and that's also something
that we are close to that is already
working on Quinto pian and that's going
to be available for everyone soon
obviously the pipeline is much more
messy than writing back and forth
multiple times so this is just an
abstraction of that so since the plot
it's mostly about back testing that's
what I'm going to focus on the remainder
of the tech talk why should you test
your code and this guy reminds us I
don't always test my code but when I do
I do it in production so you definitely
don't want to do that and night capital
proof provided a very good example of
that where due to a software bug they
lost crazy amounts for 40 million in the
stock met in a matter of seconds just
because they had this bug and other
people figured that back out and it's
and those algorithms essentially just
played that algorithm and causing huge
losses for them so one of the dangers
that can happen if you don't back test
properly so how does back testing really
work you first of all you need
historical data and that is actually a
huge problem as good data is very hard
to come by so if you have infinite
amount on to some money of course you
can just buy a really good data but free
there's Yahoo Finance which is okay but
has lots of problems and only daily
frequency so basically their frequency
is pretty much the best you can do
Google Finance offers a little bit of as
minute frequency but only for the last
couple of days but anyway we'll suppose
we have your historical data in your
database and then you'll stream it
through your algorithm and certain parts
that just reoccur like certain transform
that you want to apply moving average
you make the trading decision and then
you place the order and that's where a
lot of the complexity coming in for why
you would want a dedicated backtester
like the transaction costs or the
influence of your orders on the market
which is called slippage or the delay in
orders and those are things that the
trivial approach which would just be
what you have pennis data frame of
prices and then you generate the use
some transforms and just keep adding
columns and generate signals so you can
and many people do back test with that
but it's yet
you basically fail to account for many
complexities of the real market and that
will make your back test look much
better than it will actually be and then
finally you're just going to do
performance and risk analysis and see
how well that album did
okay so zipline is our back tester it's
written almost exclusively in Python
some of the runtime critical parts are
insight on distributed on the liberal
Apache 200 license and it's I think the
best way or like how I'd like to
describe it as stream based and what
that means is that rather than just
giving you a huge array to play with
it'll just walk through your historical
data day by day
and we'll call a function that you
define and we'll see that in a second so
that you won't have any data available
in the future and if you don't do that
it's incredibly easy actually to
introduce look ahead bias and use
information from the future that would
not be available to you that was a real
trading strategy right compare is
included so many common transforms like
moving average the sharp alpha beta
which are risk metrics we provide
and last but not least is used in
production on quantum comm so the best
way to think about that is that
quanto peon is essentially a web layer
where we provide you with three
historical data and an IDE a Python IDE
in the web browser and then that called
zip line under the hood for the actual
simulation of everything and all right
but you can also obviously use zip line
standalone which is what I'll be doing
here at first many people ask them well
are you insane why you like open
sourcing you're part of your IP and well
the one reason is that we use a lot of
open source ourselves so just giving
something back is nice but also actually
having users do pull requests on github
that fix bugs or add new features is
absolutely invaluable and the other
thing is that actually just this morning
we release the blind 0 7 in celebration
of Pi data so all the features that I'm
going to show a part of this new version
and I think it improves much of some
some words that we have before another
point that is important is
interoperability and basically
everything we input an output with zip
line is a panda's data frame so that way
it plays nicely with all of the other
libraries that you want to use right so
it's trivial to I don't know use I could
learn to try and classify on past data
and do predictions and basically tie in
that whole Python ecosystem installation
used to be much more difficult
thanks to anaconda from continuum that's
much easier now and so the easy way to
get going so standard insole anaconda
and then you can install binaries for
your platform from our quaint orchid
channel so that is the command and that
will install the the most recent 0-7
version as of this morning all right so
let's look at some actual code which is
more interesting
so their various interfaces now which is
part of the new zip lines there are
seven release and those are supposed to
make it easier to run yarder than before
where there was a whole bunch of Python
rapper code but now one of the
interfaces is command line and that is
yeah so run l Godot Pi will be installed
in your namespace once you have
installed sublime and this is just the
help file so it'll let you specify your
algorithm which we'll look at in a
second the data for you can see start
and end dates the source currently we
only support Yahoo Finance so then it
will work with that and which symbols
you want to use okay so how does trading
I wouldn't look like is that big enough
not really well
I'll show it to you in here so it's not
syntax highlighted but it's a little bit
bigger so the structure of the algorithm
is always similar and you define you
import from zip line that API you import
the functions that your algorithm
commonly uses like order for placing
orders I record I'll say something more
than a second and symbol and then always
you define two functions and in this
last function that will be called once
before the simulation starts and the
handle data function and both of those
take us the first argument of context
and that just provides you with a common
object storage that's persistent over
time and allows you to just keep track
of your variables since handle data is
called repeatedly that'll yep that'll
allow you to to deal with that so then
he initialized we don't do anything and
this handle data just implements the
simplest thing you could imagine which
is just by Apple every chance you get
and for that we make a call to the water
function and the first argument is well
which stock would you like to buy and
then we do a lookup of the Apple stock
using the symbol function and the second
argument is how many shares do you want
to buy and then the record function is
useful for tracking state of your
algorithm over time so since this is
just run in a loop over and over again
right you might want to collect certain
variables that you then want to analyze
after the simulations over and record
allows you to do that and you just
provide keyword arguments so here I'm
just creating a new variable called
Apple and that'll be the price of Apple
and here you can also see how you can
access this event frame called data that
we call you a run with and that is the
price data that you receive so this
handle data function will be called for
every trade event so every day and then
have an updated data frame that has that
way you can do basically a dictionary
lookup for Apple and then access the
most recent price of that day so that's
how you interact with data so that is
actually in a file in the example
directory of zipline and from the
command line you would call that for
example by just specifying the file name
you give it a start and end date you
provide the symbols and in this case we
have to tell it ahead of time that we
want to use Apple because once we
execute this it'll go to Yahoo Finance
scrape the data from Apple in the
specified time range and then stream
that data through our algorithm through
the handle data function that we just
looked at and then for performance
analysis it will output a pickle file
that we can specify here and then you
can just investigate that for example
now when I'm switching back to my path
notebook I can
import I can read in this pickle file
using pandas and as you can see the
result is a panda's data frame so that
is out of the mantra of using pandas
dataframes for input/output and
everything in between and the first
thing to notice off that data frame is
that it has that column apple in it and
that is the result of the record
function that i mentioned before where
for each event that happened so this
item started on the trading day in 2000
and that was the price of a single share
of Apple in that time and that was what
I extracted from that event frame called
data and then there's all kinds of other
columns that we output by default that
you might want to look at like the
orders you placed or how much capital
you used so far and one of them is also
just the portfolio value which is often
the thing you want to look at and that
just tells you how much money does my
algorithm currently have in terms of
cash but also in terms of portfolio so
if your portfolio value increases then
you're then this variable will go up so
then we can create a plot like this
where we just plot the portfolio value
next to the price of Apple and not
surprisingly this will basically track
the our portfolio value will track the
price of the Apple stock right we all we
do is just keep buying Apple obviously
our fate will be tied to that so the
other interface you can use rather than
calling it from the command line if you
like me using the app I've notebook for
everything is a so called ipython magic
and after you import zip line into your
ipython Aim space you will have this
zip line magic available to you and it
takes the same arguments at the command
line as you can see and it will
basically interpret everything inside of
that cell as being part of your trading
algorithm and then once you execute the
cell again we'll go to Yahoo Finance
download the data and run that algorithm
through the simulator and then instead
of outputting to a pickle file in this
case we place a new variable in your
namespace called perf - and that will be
as you can see here so now magically
that variable appeared that will have
the same data frame as before because we
just ran the exact same eye with them
right so those are two interfaces and
that's new in the version of 0-7 before
it just required a lot more boilerplate
I'm not going to go through here by the
way just had to manually download the
data and then call into the algorithm
and whatnot
okay so as a second example I want to
show something a little bit more
advanced functionality at least and the
idea behind the next algorithm is that
certainly just buying Apple stock every
chance you get is not very dynamic right
if you're an actual trailer then maybe
if you look at the stock price and you
bought 2000 in 2004 which would be
awesome if you did that and basically
book your flights to Vegas when the
price is here right but once it starts
coming down you probably would sell
right you would anticipate that it would
go down further obviously it's very hard
to predict but some stock certainly do
seem to have momentum and that is just
while they on this upwards trend up
until here and then they are in this
downwards trend so if you somehow can
capture that momentum then suddenly you
can profit from it
and one very simple algorithm that does
that is called the dual moving average
crossover and well just also to add
obviously this is the worst kind of
hindsight bias right if you there's no
way that you could actually predict that
would stop here or
well maybe you can but so it's a it's a
very old algorithm so I don't think it's
used much anymore but it's certainly the
straight of and before looking at the
logic I just want to show how it works
based on these lines and the idea is
that we have two moving averages and
moving averages will always try to
capture underlying trends of the market
and smooth the signal out of it and
there these two lines here the green and
the red line and there's a short moving
average that will be more impacted by
recent market movements and a long
moving average that's going to capture
more the long-term trend and what we can
do now is basically play those two
signal against each other and say well
if we want to detect an upwards movement
right then we assume that there's this
long-term movement that's pretty steady
and a recent increase and the short
moving average will essentially pass
through the long moving average and
because it's more impacted by this
recent increase as is the case over here
and then we want to buy the stock and
once basically there's a trend going
down as is the case over here the short
moving average will capture that much
quicker than the long moving average so
it'll pass from above and that's when we
want to exit our positions you can also
see that then here in the portfolio
value where again the portfolio value
will be tied to the price of Apple as
long as we are invested in that stock
but once we sell it it's just a flat
line because our cash doesn't doesn't
change over time and we're not invested
and then we can essentially just try to
write these ups and exit our positions
on the downs so the main difference to
the argument before is that now we need
access to more than just the current
event but we want to look at say the
last 50 days or the last 200 days and
for that we also have a new feature that
works much better than before called
history which I'm importing up here and
what that does is just
keeps moving window as a panda's data
frame and each time you call that
function you just get the last 50 days
as as that pandas dataframe and for that
in the initialized function we first
have to register that you want to use it
so that internally we can keep track of
it and for that you call the ad history
function first argument is how many days
do you want to track these are the wrong
numbers and so our short moving average
will be 50 days and the other one will
be 200 days this is just the the unit
time for the first argument and then
which variable we want to track in this
case the price so then in the handle
data function for the first 200 days
we're just going to wait until our
windows are filled up filled up so I'm
just going to return until we are at
that point and then the we can compute
the short moving average by just calling
that history function with the same
parameters before and that will return
that pennis data frame on which we can
call the mean function and in that case
as it's a moving window just calling the
mean over and over again will just give
us moving average and then we have the
long moving average in the same manner
and here we implement the central
trading logic which is just well is the
short moving average over the long
moving average in which case we want to
buy the positions and here I'm using
instead of just the order method with
just orders five shares every time you
call their function it actually achieves
a target rate of shares that you want to
keep in your portfolio so if in this
case I'm calling it with 100 shares so
if I have 0 it'll place an order of 100
if I already have 100 it won't do
anything so that is just a neat way of
not trying to keep track whether I
already bought the stock or not I can
just call that function and know that
it'll work because this condition will
be true for a whole range of time or in
the other case we want to exit our
position so we'll just set
our target shares to zero and again we
use the record function to then record
these values I'm recording the Apple
price the short moving average and the
long moving average that's what it below
used then to create that debt plot and
you can also define analyze function
that will be called after the after the
algorithm has run and then you can use
that to generate plots as as I did here
okay so the ette pretty much just a
short intro for zipline and this largely
based on the tutorial that we have so
before also users complain well it's
really difficult to get going so that's
whether it's this tutorial to walk you
through the the main concepts but in the
remaining time also want to show you
canto pian real quickly so maybe you
don't want to set up all this yourself
so this is what quanto pin looks like
and this is basically the ide that we
provide for you in the web browser and
on the left is should look very familiar
you again have the initialize function
and the Hetal data function here i'm
using a slightly different way to
calculate the moving average there's a
current ongoing effort of trying to make
the algorithm that you develop in
zipline just directly copy/paste able to
canto pian and it's already working in
many instances for this specific case
not yet but it will work soon that it
could just really copy paste the code
from before and then here it's just the
same logic as before right and i can use
the record function but in this case so
let's say now build the algorithm it'll
actually now use the data that we have
from you know internal database and that
is much more high quality than what you
who provides so this is cleaned up and
adjusted for splits and mergers and
dividends and all of that and in blue
you see the portfolio value in of our
algorithm and in red you see the
benchmarks off we want to know well how
good does matter
doing comparison to the benchmark and
you get all of these risk metrics as
well and the record function will call
will cause that these variables are also
tracked and plot it in real time down
here so it's just basically a much more
integrated environment and you can
directly choose here that the time range
and how you want to start and the other
neat thing is that instead of daily data
we also provide you minute level
resolution which is all more useful if
you want to really develop more
fine-grained algorithms so the other
thing that I want to show you then is
the community so everything you
developing here is your own intellectual
property and is is your own it's not
public but some users just for fun or
for getting good feedback and learning
open up the algorithms and discuss that
in our forum so you can just click on a
post and there it will explain basically
the idea behind that algorithm and how
it was developed and you can see in a
very similar manner as before just the
the performance of the algorithm you see
the risk metrics and you also get the
source code of what that user did to
implement the logic so that's really
great way to to get going and learn how
to use the platform but also how to
develop better trading organs right and
also really cool is that you can just
now say you want to really bad at
zooming and play around with it out with
and so you can just say clone algorithm
and what it will do now is Bailey just
copy all of that logic over to my own
IDE where I can edit it and and run it
myself so that's really the idea of this
collaboration and bringing that open
source idea where people can just build
on top of each other and then I could
post a response on that forum and say
okay here I
improved in that manner or fix that bug
and the other nice thing that you can
could also now do is actually forward
test that algorithm and also deployed
live with your own money so it can
connect it to your own broker account
and then it'll actually use for example
this trading strategy to to invest and
you can see not only how well would it
have done if it was 2002 but also how
well is it doing in current market
situations right and that is I think the
most stringent test for algorithms
because there is no way you can have
look at head bias in that way and even
with the back testing just as soon as
you start using Apple it's already
invalid right because everyone knows of
the last couple of years Apple did very
well and then as a last thing something
we did
if you expect you all expert Python
programs but if you're not you can also
actually create algorithms without
anything without any coding by using
this algorithm builder and here you can
select from different sectors and
essentially that will just be an equally
weighted portfolio now or actually not
equally weighted but you can set the
weights you own and say okay which
sector so let's choose clean tech and I
want to have 20% of my portfolio or
maybe let's say 25 because like Tesla
allocated to Tesla Motors incorporated
and just set the portfolio as you would
like to have it and you can choose the
rebalancing frequency and for example
let's do it every 30 days so without any
coding now essentially we created this
algorithm that will rebalance and always
keep the portfolio weights at this time
at this level and in this case it worked
out really well
okay so I think that's it for the
platform inclusions I think the benefit
of using zip line as opposed to
contouring is that they're you really
have full control of the platform right
so some users really like to use their
own data or anything like that
so for that it's it can be more powerful
but certainly Kanto pian gives you all
the nice the niceties and helping you
develop and the community and the data
and ultimately the goal and I think
we're there
soon is to read be able to copy/paste
your your algorithm so that you can go
back and forth between those two
anything that'd be the best of both
worlds so thanks a lot and we have some
time for questions
yes thanks how was the right benchmark
line defined said again for the right
benchmark line in a quant oaken how was
it defined that is the sp500 in that
case so yeah you can
in that case yeah you just want to have
a general benchmark off the overall
market so that you know that it's easy
to do well if the market goes up but you
can also set that benchmark your own for
example if we're doing that do a moving
average example against Apple then maybe
the the we want to know whether we're
doing better than Apple or not so then
you can set that as a benchmark and
compare I can that yeah yes so how do
you do actual valid best back testing as
you said if you select Apple you already
are super biased so how else do you do
it so one good way I think is to select
the universe and we have a function for
that where you can say set universe and
then you just one way to construct the
big universe is just to rank order
according to the dollar volume the
stocks and then say I want to have from
the 98th to the 99th percentile all
stocks that have this trading volume or
in that percentile I want to use so
you're not hand picking stocks which is
a terrible idea you're just using
whatever was traded a lot and that
protects against that and in the best
way right yeah in the beginning you say
but you want to select this slice from
your universe but the universe also
changes and over time as like other
stocks come in and trade more than
others and then we also actually behind
the scenes will update that portfolio
and give you the updated stock so it'll
it'll move it as well I have a question
how do you do a forward testing with
just using zip line so without uploading
the the code - kwinto peon
yeah so currently that's not supported
you could maybe make your own somehow
but for that the main thing you need is
just a live data feed and let's say
that's available you know I don't know I
guess yeah so you could just write code
to like call your handle data function
so the whole thing is very iterative
based so actually if you just like hook
into the underlying iterator you can
just call it with your own data source
and as new events become available it'll
just hook into the existing machinery
and and call it so it'll just be a very
slow back test but there's no issue with
that so there is a hook that I could
override in the plant to do that right
yeah so actually let me retract my
answer it's way easier you just define
your own trade source and all we do is
essentially treating that as an iterator
and for looping into that so in that
case so before it's often a data frame
and we just like go row by row and
return that but in your case your trade
sauce would just return a new event
every time it's available and runs until
infinity so there's no problem with them
yeah okay thank you so there was a
question here so what what kind of risk
metrics do you support the app valued
risk kind of I think we have value at
risk so yeah there's alpha there's beta
I think I can show to you there is the
Sharpe ratio Sortino Value at Risk I
think we added a couple of new ones
recently and so I think here is a
complete list
right next role on
yeah those are information ratio those
are the main ones
so yeah in in zipline since it's all
open source you can just add a new one
and actually some users already for
example the sateen oh we got a pull
request from a user who just implemented
that function and hooked it up and then
once it's in zipline it'll end up pretty
soon on kwinto peon so on that note the
zipline version that's open source is
exactly the same what we're using on
contour peon so whatever user
contributes it'll actually then also
contributed here also contributed to
Kanto pian and be available to much
larger community there so yeah if
there's anything missing looking forward
to EPR hi effects it was very
interesting but I understood that
algorithmic trading is really has to be
as fast as possible and millisecond make
a difference how that I mean if you
implement a good algorithm but maybe you
don't do it fast enough then how does
the impact your actual gain so yeah I
mean that's you debate of whether only
high-frequency trading works or whether
anything works it's certainly there are
quite a few strategies for example well
so the easiest way to answer that
question would be for example an index
fund
there's use demand for that and those
seem to do pretty well in their low
volatility but track the market and here
you can basically create your own index
fund by for example using the algorithm
if you don't want a lot if you don't
believe that like there's patterns that
you can learn with so I could learn you
could just do that and essentially avoid
paying the next one P okay so let's
thank our speaker once again
you